one September I was out for a stroll in
the High Country of Northern New Mexico
when a creamy flash of color caught my
eye Out Among the dark trunks of trees
it was the rump of a young calf elk a
little male I crept in closer watching
for cows the females that would be
nearby the calf was greedily snarfing
down on some green grass he'd found in
this little clearing I watched him for a
few minutes catching glimpses of the
legs and the sides and the Tawny rumps
of adult elk that were drifting around
in the area
and just as I wondered where this calf's
mother was she called to him
it was calm
inquisitive just a check-in he barely
flicked his ears and went on tearing
away at the grass
a minute passed and I could imagine her
standing there staring intently in the
direction she'd last seen him
[Music]
her second call had a different ring a
glimmer of agitation maybe a flash of
concern
he just went on to scarfing away at the
grass completely ignoring her
even I was starting to get annoyed with
him come on dude your mom is worried
about you
yeah
she was officially upset I could hear
the gentleness go from her voice her
call took on a raspy hiss and his head
snapped up and he went bounding off to
her the whole thing made me chuckle I
had just witnessed a scenario right out
of any parent's typical day and anyone
sitting alongside me would have been
able to understand that situation
today I want to take a few minutes to
talk about paying attention to what's
being said out there by all the other
Critters it's something important and
Incredibly useful to our relationship
with the wild world as modern humans we
are so caught up in ourselves and in our
own little worlds that most of us go
about life thinking the animals make
random noises or that their
Communications are beyond our
comprehension and some of them are but
there's more universality and
vocalizations than we might think
listening and learning from the calls of
animals is a basic life skill and it was
always advantageous for humans to pay
attention
the British Hunter Jim Corbett pointed
this out more than a century ago he grew
up in the jungles of India and Rose to
Fame in the early 1900s for his ability
to hunt down man-eating Tigers he was an
incredible Woodsman and he absolutely
loved tigers and all of the other
Critters of the Wilds that he was raised
in he often said that one would always
know what was happening in the jungle
whether a tiger was on the prowl or a
group of Travelers were passing through
because the animals would tell you he
wrote All Birds and all animals have
their own language and though with few
exceptions one species cannot speak the
language of another species all the
jungle folk understand each other's
language
when we start listening there is a world
of information we can glean the more
familiar we are with birds and other
Wildlife the better but we don't need to
be able to identify birds by ear or know
all the sounds that wild animals make we
just need to change what we listen for
and what we observe
birds are great to focus on because like
us they are super vocal and because
they're so vocal they're very keen
listeners a lot of folks get very good
at deciphering bird language studying
how birds respond differently to
particular Predators or how alarms
reverberate through a forest but let's
keep it simple and start with the
essentials what's important and so
gratifying is that we can quickly learn
to recognize what's happening in the
woods around us all the other animals do
it so why not us
first birds don't make noise without a
reason there's something being conveyed
in each vocalization to understand what
that is we'll want to focus on two
things in the auditory realm we want to
pay attention to the inflection of each
vocalization we hear
the other thing we want to pay attention
to is body language
imagine seeing a friend or a spouse
moving around the kitchen saying to
themselves as they make a cup of coffee
or put the dishes away and now imagine
that same person sitting at the computer
cursing at the screen because the time
sensitive documents that they're
uploading keep freezing and they keep
getting taken back to the start page we
don't need to understand the words that
person is saying they could be speaking
in an entirely different language we
know everything we need to from the
difference in their voice as it goes
from relaxed to agitated
and we can see the change in their body
too the tension we can feel all of it in
the same way we can pay careful
attention to the inflection and the body
language of other animals around us
especially birds begin to focus on how
they sound on how they look and where
their attention is
picture a bird feeding on the ground or
picking seeds from a feeder the calls
they make to each other are mellow and
chattery they are alert and Vigilant but
their bodies are relaxed life is good
and now imagine that a cat has sculpt
onto the scene the birds take notice
their calls take on a harsher tone and
after hearing the calls and the alarms
of others birds that haven't seen the
cat will also go into full alert their
bodies tense up they'll start stretching
their necks out to get a better View and
they'll hop rigidly from Branch to
Branch with palpable agitation some
might also flick their tails their whole
body is pumping with each alarm call
the point is it's much easier to see and
hear animals telling us that something
is not right or that everything is good
then most of us think it is
understanding the language of animals
isn't woo-woo or just some cheesy
anthropomorphizing it's a practical
skill that's useful in Wild places can
even save your life I'll give you an
example
I am a senior tracker and an
international evaluator with cyber
tracker conservation a global
organization that originated in South
Africa to train and assess the skills of
professional Wildlife trackers one part
of the assessment process is to evaluate
how well a Tracker follows a set of
tracks with the intention of finding the
animal that made them but without
alerting the animal to his or her
presence
if the tracker misses bird alarms or the
alarms of other animals points are
docked from their score and they might
even be taken off the trail why well
because in South Africa and in some
places in the United States missing
those signals can result in US walking
right smack into the back end of a
dangerous animal
but we don't need the presence of danger
for this practice to be so rewarding
being alert and aware and tuned in helps
us learn more about what's happening in
the woods around us we might know that
there's a predator around like a bobcat
or an owl or a snake and being tuned in
enables us to know when we're causing a
disturbance and helps us avoid
disrupting the woods
listening requires us to stop and check
in which gives us an immediate feel for
where we are and tuning into all the
voices out there creates in us a deep
sense of connection to place think about
it this way each landscape has a unique
soundscape that broadcasts a symphony of
information about the living world and
soundscape ecology is the study of how
living organisms interrelate
acoustically with each other and with
their environment Bernie Krauss the
father of soundscape ecology and an
expert at recording natural soundscapes
made incredible contributions to our
understanding of ecosystems this way
he began to point out in the 1960s that
one of the best ways to get to know a
place is to listen to it he spent the
better part of his life recording and
studying more than 1300 habitats he said
careful listening gives us incredibly
valuable tools by which to evaluate the
health of a habitat across the entire
spectrum of life
so over the next few days your field
assignment is to stop and listen pay
attention to these sounds around you at
different times of day and night what is
the soundscape of your home turf
regardless of whether you live in a city
or way out in the woods
and listen to birds and watch them
listen for inflection study their body
language you'll start to notice all
sorts of behaviors relaxed Birds bathing
or preening
young birds fluttering their wings as
they beg for food from their parents or
upset Birds yelling at Intruders
soak it all up
Foster this practice so that no matter
where you are a little part of your
brain is always tuned to listening to
what the birds are saying about life in
a forest or in a park or along city
streets
we are not alone in this world it's
bigger than us and when we turn our
attention to the voices of the others we
learn to listen to a universal language
there is a lot being said out there
foreign
[Music]